this is a production of cornell
university
hello my name is carl scamenti from the
cornell turf grass program
and today i'm going to go through a
really quick tutorial on how to use the
web soil survey
this online free tool that gives you a
lot of information about the soils at
your property
really quickly so you know first thing
just type in
in google web soil survey you'll find
this page
and if you want to read more about the
you know the data that goes into the web
solar survey how they did it you can but
um easiest way to do it is just click
the green button to get started
and you'll get right to the online tools
so a lot of things kind of going on in
this website but
the best way to start is just to put in
the address of
the site you're interested in today
we're just going to use the robert trent
jones golf course
at cornell um
i could put in the exact address but
instead i'll just type in a
name of the golf course and that gets me
at least in tompkins county now i'm just
using the zoom in zoom out feature
to find our golf course here now we're
zeroing in on it
there we go so here's robert jones golf
course
so now okay what do i do i have to draw
my boundary around
the area i'm interested in so we see
these uh
shapes aoi that means area of interest
i'm going to click on this one which
will just allow me to
basically draw a boundary of the area
so i'm just going to circle our front
line here at cornell
and then uh kind of a little tricky
thing here doesn't really explain it but
you have to double click
to kind of confirm this and there we go
it created our area of interest
and and that's pretty easy now we can go
in and look at a bunch of
information on our soils the first thing
you can do is just click soil map
and here we go generates a pretty
detailed map right you can see of the
soils at your golf course
has all the information it's got the
corresponding map unit
uh sandy loam gravely loan right silty
clay loam
uh and then a cool little aspect is is
the percentage of the property that is
that soil type two so already i see
almost fifty percent is this
hudson silty clay loam that's
interesting
um and so then you can kind of go a
little bit deeper
actually a lot deeper and you can look
at all the information in the soil data
explorer
i like to go to the soil properties and
qualities area and really kind of
investigate all of the things that you
can look at
there's a lot of information here right
chemical properties
soil health soil physical properties i
like to go to
the drainage class which is under soil
qualities and features right here
so when you go into any one of these
selections
you can just go ahead and view the
rating and it spits out that map again
now it color codes it
based on the drainage class so when i
scroll down
i can look at my soils i look at
what they're rated right so we see some
poorly drained somewhat poorly drained
soils
these rhinebeck silk loams make up over
20 percent of the property
so then we can go up we can look at rka
rkb
where does that correspond on the map
okay we look at some really
kind of very specific areas that have
these soil types
and that might correspond to things
you've seen on the property before
the composition of the turf grass
species in that area
those are probably going to be wetter
areas if you ever noticed them before
this might help you target maybe soil
sampling
or drainage installation so certainly
some information here that might
correspond to patterns you've seen in
the past
but could also be really useful for
things you want to do in the future so
that's just one of you know literally
hundreds of things you can
go looking for in this web soil survey
again it's free pretty easy to use once
you once you do it once or twice
and then if you want to kind of print
all this stuff out
they have this shopping cart here tab uh
in the top right you can just click
check out and
what that'll do i've already got my
little report here
it'll generate a report for you so this
is what it looks like
you can scroll through this uh one of
the nice parts is it will make a map for
you so i think it's always useful for
someone to have the
soil map just just as a print out in the
office in the maintenance area
so everybody can kind of see what's
what's going on out there if they notice
things
you can start keeping notes and seeing
if um certain turf grass issues
correspond to also the soil issues
out on the property uh and then of
course there's a bunch of information
about each soil type so you can have
this in a
in a binder if you want in your office
um so that's web show
survey um you know a note for newer golf
courses where there's been a significant
amount of soil moved
ground move to create the golf course
this data depending on when it was taken
may not be super representative after
you've disturbed
the area like that but for older golf
courses a really great tool
uh to give some insight on your property
thanks for watching see you next time
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu